you two play lifelong friends did you
know each other before this series
we did not know each other uh but it it
i i i when we were working i thought
were we like a weekend and i a week into
shooting and i said to you it felt it
feels like i've known you my entire life
yeah yeah we were we were really fast
we had a very quick connection
literally like i feel like we've had
past lives together that was how that
was how close and and familiar it felt
for me with octavia
um
and it was so wonderful because you know
you're coming into it you're we're
coming into a show where we play really
like old old family friends right it was
very nice to have to feel that
comfortable with octavia
that's why
about past lives like literally 20
minutes ago anyway
what was the one thing about each other
that made this friendship or this this
working relationship that turned into a
friendship really click for you both
on screen or off screen
maybe both
well i've always been a fan of kate's
and just revered her talent
and
so when you when you see a person that
that gifted you know i want to work with
them and then you meet them in real life
and they bring everything you ever
dreamed of to the table and then they
turn out to be just really amazing
people
so ground rounded so humble and i'm not
the only one who felt like they'd donor
uh
their whole lives i mean our entire uh
returning past like don't you just love
kate doesn't feel like she's been here
the whole time
and so
um i would say
i would say those attributes
are
really
who you are kate you're just a special
person
thanks octavia i would i would honestly
i mean this is going to sound like a
love fest but i would return the
sentiment you know and octavia is our
leader she's the you know executive
producer and star of this show and she
sets the tone for everything
and she's warm and she's kind it's
generous
and
and
full of light
and
um
and that just makes everybody feel
just
absolutely good and happy to be at work
every day and then on top of it as a
scene partner
you know
i have a real
you know we we one day we had a lot of
lines and
one day i i just was like isn't it so
nice to like i actually maybe it was
octavia who said this but to actually
work with someone like that's really
prepared
we know what we're like we're pro well
yeah we're pros right like we show up we
know what we're doing we did our
homework um and and for me i i you know
i really i do care about you know story
and
and making sure that we're being really
honest with our delivery and
and kind of
working through some things and i just
had such an amazing partner in octavia
it was like
obviously you know but but what a dream
um because some you never know what to
expect some people aren't as generous
even though they're brilliant
um
so
it was wonderful create such a safe
space for sure kate this is your first
lead role in a tv series why did you
choose truth be told
well i mean you're look i i just
answered it
it was all right but also
on top of it you know obviously it's
octavia
reese is a one of my oldest friends
actually and a producer on this uh so we
spoke about it a lot apple to work with
apple is also an absolute dream they
take such good care of you and also i
mean we did this during a pandemic so
they they really set a a very safe stage
for us
and and
um but the character i mean you have
michelle wrote a great character in
micah keith she's
very dynamic it allowed me to kind of
explore themes of narcissism and really
interesting kind of behavioral dynamics
from someone like micah
and and so
it was fun for me you know as just
to to play that out you know i also
hadn't been on a movie since fool's gold
movie show i've never done a show but
the only the only film i'd ever done
uh or the
closest uh was fool's gold that was six
months
and this was seven
yeah so it had been a while since i'd
done something that we'd really like
been in
together as a family like that for that
long
and it was so wonderful i just loved it
you know i
i am
it made me miss it it also it also
reinforced to me how important it is to
work with people that you really
admire um that are that are incredibly
gifted like octavia
oh the trailer of the new season asks
who do you trust with your deepest
secrets so i want that to ask that
question to both of you octavia who do
you trust with your deepest secrets
i well it's it's just my
closest friends in in my family yeah i i
mean
they i'm an open book to to my my
friends and family
so
okay
i like tell everybody everything
i mean not in a not in a
not like i mean obviously there's things
that i don't share with everybody but i
don't feel like i have that much to hide
right so and i'm really oh i don't know
secrets like
i don't have deep secrets
right because i i live pretty much like
out on my i live everything sort of more
externally
um
that being said
my attorney knows a lot of secrets
i'm just kidding uh
no um
i'd say my mom you know my mom is my
confidant i go to my mom about the you
know the stuff
yeah i go to your mom too she's amazing
me too come on yeah everybody should go
to my mom she's like a really good
um from the mind up program to all yeah
just dm goldie she she'll know
yeah you know
yeah she's got some answers
can you play media a media mogul
uh you have a bit of entrepreneurial you
know spirit of your own do you have a
lot in common with your character would
you say
in particular i mean i think i think um
i think
one thing i can understand is when
people turn to you to ask you
what to do or what the advice is or
you know a lot of times someone will
turn to me and be like what do i do
about this and i'm like i don't know i'm
not an expert
uh
you know but i can tell you what i would
i do you know but i think micah is
different so micah actually believes
that part of herself uh she believes
that she has
you know that she that she really is
that person for people
um
and
kind of i think you know buys into that
which i think can be a dangerous cycle
for a lot of people
um
like a big difference between owning
knowledge and wisdom and then buying
buying the hype you know
um
and and so that was interesting what
would i
but other than that you know
um
i uh
i i i i know i know what it's like to be
a and
sort of to build business yeah but it
would it's it's quite different than
this
yeah
octavia it was fun for me to do the
speaking though i have to say i actually
enjoyed
the speaking you know
i did i in a weird way i was like oh
this is kind of fun with like the little
wire and
you know
getting out in front of people and
actually like i i i you know i i i'm not
afraid of a stage
um
so and you made it look easy
you made it look easy
amazing well thank you ladies i just got
the rap signal thanks for your time
you're both like my dream saturday so
this is the best thing
thank you so much
you